great well thank you my name is Katie
dykes I'm the
Commissioner for energy at the
Connecticut Department of Energy and
Environmental Protection and I'm just
really grateful to the Yale climate
energy institute and to Senator Murphy
for convening us today and and
especially impressed by all of you for
returning out I am a recovering a long
time Yale student and it wasn't that
long ago but i can't remember friday
classes ever being very popular let
alone voluntarily showing up on a friday
afternoon this late so i think it is a
testament to the importance of this
topic and appreciate the great turnout
and support for talking about this issue
you know i'm really struck it's here at
hearing some of the other some of the
presentations and obviously the emphasis
on the need to have a much more
resilient infrastructure if we're going
to adapt to climate change and i think
that my experience i came to work at
deep which is our acronym about a year
and a half ago and and one of the things
that has really struck me is that if
we're going to have our regulatory and
policy planning system encourage and
support a more resilient infrastructure
it has to start with the design of the
the government entity itself and
connecticut has taken a really important
and innovative step in trying to make
sure that climate change is integrated
into all aspects of our policy and
planning through the reorganization that
occurred in july 2011 that created the
department where i work essentially you
took to take the federal analogue that
it would have been the EPA and you
merged it with FERC and added a DOA on
top and mushed it all together and and
that's essentially what was created with
our new department we took the former
Department of Environmental Protection
here in Connecticut merged it with the
public utilities control authority and
then created a new policy energy policy
Bureau and through this this or
reorganization you know what's happened
is that
now instead of having separate silos
where we think about environmental
policy and regulation over here and then
we regulate utilities over here and
think about energy issues now we're
challenged to do that all in one in one
structure and it's very exciting it's
very it's very challenging but I think
we're starting to see some of the
results of that that new organization
being reflected in the policies that
we're developing here in the state
governor malloy has been a real has
championed a vision of cheaper and
cleaner and more reliable energy for
Connecticut through a variety of
different initiatives that we've been
working on my part of the department
focuses on the energy aspects and
climate change has been integral to to
all of that we have a very critical task
here in adapting our our energy system
to to climate change we're doubling down
on our investment in energy efficiency
here in Connecticut and we are engaged
right now in procuring additional
renewables to increase the the
cleanliness of our energy supply we have
really been pursuing this on a whole
range of fronts Connecticut has been a
leader in something that's called the
Regional Greenhouse Gas Initiative and
we're very pleased to see now the EPA
and and leadership in Washington
including Senator Murphy ensuring that
other states are going to start taking
steps to clean up the energy our
electricity system so that other states
can catch up to what we've been doing
here in New England and Connecticut but
as I said governor moyes you know vision
it it's cheaper cleaner and more
reliable and each one of those
components is is absolutely important
it's no easy a task to accomplish this
in Connecticut where we have some of the
highest electricity prices in the
continental US and it's no easy task in
a state where we have had to experience
the the major storms that have been
detailed by some of
the panel is so far in 2011 2012
hurricane sandy tropical storm irene the
october snow storm that knocked out
power to 800,000 of the 1.2 million
customers of just one of our utility
companies here in the state you know I
know senator Murphy had observed about
you know we may not see the the fabric
of democracy unraveling here in
Connecticut as a result of drought or
some of these other impacts but if you
cut off power and electricity to homes
and businesses across the state and
people are without a shower and a dead
cell phone and and and sitting in the
cold it may not be long before you start
having armed revolution so and not to be
light about it but it the economic
impacts of storm outages are no joke the
the safety concerns the impacts on
public health are very severe and so for
that reason taking our the governor's
vision of cheaper cleaner more reliable
we've sat down to say you know what can
we do to ensure that our energy
infrastructure is prepared for climate
change and so we've been pursuing an
aggressive multi-faceted strategy to
improve the resiliency of our electric
grid through hardening transmission and
distribution lines undergrounding those
lines where it's appropriate installing
stronger poles shifting to a smart grid
so we can detect outages faster and more
precise locations engaging in a
vegetation management program the right
tree right place to ensure you know a
lot of the power lines are brought down
by limbs falling and so making sure that
we're minimizing those risks but even if
we achieve that all of these resiliency
gains with these approaches there will
still be outages hurricanes blizzards
ice storms they're going to take down
wires and poles and the lights are going
to go out the power may be up ninety
nine point seven percent of the time but
when it goes out it's a tremendous and
convenience to the public and a threat
to public safety and a detriment to
commerce into our economy and so we have
puzzle
around to find out what what kind of
insurance policy can we take out what
kind of system can we put in place to
moderate the burdens when those outages
occur and we found one in in the form of
microgrids microgrids are a series of
critical they're basically tiny tiny
little electrical grids they're a series
of critical facilities could be a gas
station a hospital school police station
that are linked together by electric
light distribution lines empowered by a
distributed generation system so that
they can continue to provide power when
the main grid goes down so there's these
complicated trips and transfers is what
they're called that essentially flick a
switch so that when the when the grid
has an outage that that's that little
micro grid will island itself or isolate
itself so it can continue providing
power last year we had the legislature
gave the green light to a bond funding
to support a very innovative micro grid
grant program this is the first in the
in the nation to have we are the first
to have a statewide micro grid program
which is very exciting and also a little
lonely because we've been casting about
to try to find you know answers to some
of the fundamental questions about how
to develop these there's some complex
technical and engineering challenges
that need to be overcome there's legal
and regulatory obstacles that have to be
addressed as well as how to fund them
and there are a lot of exciting examples
that out there on the military actually
has developed a lot of these but what
we've tried to do is adapt these micro
grid system so that they can support not
just public buildings but also to that
you can network together private
buildings as well critical facilities
includes your police and fire and
prisons sewage treatment plans but it
also can mean putting together a senior
center linking it with a gas station a
grocery store so that they can stay up
and running or could be a place to even
just charge your cell phone while the
grid is down
so it's been very exciting to see this
program unfold we went out with a
request for proposals we got dozens of
towns and businesses that responded this
summer we announced that we've selected
nine facilities to move forward and then
we're also that later this year in this
fall going to be announcing another
round so that we can get even more of
these micro grids developed in
Connecticut and just 11 pointed to think
about on this you know as I said cheaper
cleaner more reliable the micro grid
solution is one that improves the
reliability of our electric system but
we also wanted to achieve those other
policy goals and I think this is where
it's so important to have to be thinking
in an integrated way about how to
address the short-term impacts of
climate change and also at the same time
the long-term impacts and the long-term
planning needed to reduce a carbon
output that's contributing to climate
change so one of the criteria that we've
included when we've been developing
these micro grids is that these should
be micro grids that are not just turning
on when the the power is down but that
they are able to provide a distributed
generation solution on a 24-7 basis that
they're powered by the cleanest
generation sources possible so that not
only are they going to provide those
benefits in the event of fortunately of
an electric outage but they can also
help to offset and displace fossil fuel
generation that's running on a
continuing basis so it's a really
exciting program I just wanted to
mention that just as one example of one
of one of the initiatives that we've
been engaged in at the Department of
Energy and Environmental Protection
reflecting on our combined mission of
energy environment that's helping to
we're address some of the impacts of
climate change on our on our electric
system so thank you so much i look
forward to the questions at the end
you